thank you very much and thanks for
coming on this beautiful Saturday
morning my name is Adisa said is Leslie
Kenna and I'm a clinical pharmacologist
and that means that I work on trying to
figure out how to make drugs as safe and
effective as they possibly can be but
today I'm going to talk about something
a little different I'm gonna talk about
a tool that scientists use to discover
new medicines and I'm gonna work over
here just so I can run my slides and my
talk is how far applies light the way
way to new drugs now one of the most
important things in science is to
acknowledge all the help you get and
that's where I want to start Doug all
dr. Doug auld at the National Human
Genome Research Institute at the NIH a
terrific scientist and a great person
gave me the idea on how to run what
you'll see is the luciferase assay and
he helped me get the materials and
walked me through the demonstration so
I'm very grateful to him the pro
mega-corporation provided some materials
for the reaction which was an extremely
generous donation on their part
and I want to thank Patti woulding and
Anissa Ramirez from Yale University for
this fine Saturday program because they
did a lot also to help me get here today
okay so this is a picture of my
four-year-old son catching fireflies in
the yard this past June here he is and I
don't know about you but no matter how
old I get this just never ceases to be
fun for me I mean if I wasn't taking a
picture you'd see I was out there
running with him trying to catch them
and then I don't know if you could see
here just when he stopped trying to
chase after them there was one right
there behind him but fireflies are not
just fun they're also a very important
tool they've been an important tool for
scientists to discover new medication
and so I don't know about when you saw
the title of this talk what you are
imagining but were you thinking that do
you think that scientists collect a lot
of fireflies stick them in a jar and
then go and look in the medicine cabinet
well that's one way
what I'm gonna talk about today is even
more exciting than that and pretty
sophisticated stuff so to get to that
point we're gonna have to talk about a
couple other things but by the end I
think you'll have a good understanding
of of what I what I mean and what
scientists are doing so the first thing
we're going to talk about is why do
fireflies glow in the dark you know from
my perspective you know it always seemed
like I didn't really care that much
because it just was fun but they're
they're doing something important when
they're glowing in the dark second how
do they glow what is it that makes
fireflies glow we'll talk about that and
then finally we'll get to the big
question which is how have scientists
use this glowing to find new medications
and I want to point out that I'm not
just gonna be standing up here or
lecturing to you the whole time I'm
gonna do some demonstrations and talk
about the science so you understand it
and then after when I'm done you'll have
plenty of time to play around with the
things that I show in my talk so we're
gonna learn a couple big words today and
I thought let's start out and get one
out of the way right away here's one
does anyone want can somebody say this
word bioluminescence have you heard this
word before okay all right so great this
is a very educated group
it just means living light fancy way of
saying glow okay and what do you know
about fireflies when you look at them it
was the whole Firefly lighting up or
where is it coming from yeah well if you
turn it over they call that that part
here where the glow is coming from they
call that the lantern okay and so does
anyone know why fireflies glow in the
dark yes
yes okay I don't know if everybody heard
that but fireflies glow in the dark
because they're certain searching for
mates and by flashing that's
communicating to other fly of flies to
you know come find me
but fireflies are not the only creatures
that are bioluminescent there are a lot
of other living things that bioluminesce
and what's interesting is that they all
do it for very different reasons and
here's a you know a list of reasons one
is finding mates two is to lure prey or
you know find dinner three is to attract
some kind of insect or animal that's
going to spread their spores around and
then four is to evade predators or to
avoid being eaten themselves okay and
I'm going to show you some images of
these things in action for example
though to evade predators there are some
animals in the deep sea that have
they're able to release that
bioluminescent cotton the glowing stuff
and they spread that around so that
predators get confused when they're
coming and then they can't catch them
okay does anyone has anyone seen this
before okay what does this guy do this
angler fish oh hi
right so he's got this guy he's got a
glowing thing on top of his head this is
a fish he lives it 225 to 12,000 feet
below the ocean surface so does anyone
know about what what it's like down
there I heard someone say it yeah very
very dark I can't see your finger in
front of you
anybody have a guess how many what
percent of animals that live down there
are able to bioluminesce 10% that's a
good guess it's higher
funny even higher keep going higher 90%
is that 90% of the creatures that live
is that those deep depths in the ocean
can bioluminesce and so this is one
creature and I'm gonna show you a video
of him in action him or her sorry
so what you're seeing here is the glow
of the bulb on top of its head and
inside there are microorganisms that
bioluminesce blue and this thing is
swimming around and it's bully you know
this he's glowing it is glowing and this
fish is looking for our food and so I'm
sorry it's very dark but that's how it
is down there and this is we couldn't
see the glowing if it wasn't like this
okay that I think I believe that's just
some other kind of bioluminescent
organism that's down there in the ocean
with it and I have to point out that I
took a lot of these clips from YouTube
because I don't have the ability to go
down into the ocean and collect these
myself so there's another organism
that's bioluminescent down there okay so
this is how he gets his name the angler
fish it's like angling with a fishing
line swinging it around Oh turn off the
lights and then here comes a cuttlefish
which is attracted to this light and I
believe it's because you know down at
that depth you have to remember 90% of
things are luminescent so this
cuttlefish is looking at it and thinking
well maybe that's food and so I think
the angler fish just ate them kind of
cruel okay so we've seen fireflies light
up to me angler fish light up to attract
prey there are some mushrooms fungi that
bioluminesce and you can see it in the
at night there's kind of a glow on the
forest floor
and these are believed to be doing it to
attract animals to spread their spores
around and it does anybody know where
this is taken yes yes have you been
there how maybe you should tell us about
it
okay and so yes so this is they call it
bioluminescent Bay in Puerto Rico it's
this body of water where they have just
an incredible concentration of these
bioluminescent dinoflagellates
dinoflagellates are simple organisms
that have a little whip-like tail and
they move around but when they get distr
herbs they glow and if you run your hand
through the water they are the water
lights up so that's what this person is
doing and apparently the reason why they
do it is they do it to avoid being eaten
and how it works is if they sense that
something is going to try to if they get
disturbed you know if they're afraid
that something's going to eat them they
light up and apparently it attracts
bigger fish to come into the area and so
then those bigger fish then eat the
smaller fish that was about to eat them
and here is a little video of somebody
throwing a rock into one of these bodies
of water that bioluminesce you'll see
coole I want to see that again I never
tire of looking at that hold on
I love that okay so we've talked about
why fireflies and other bioluminescent
creatures glow and now we could talk
about how they glow okay so I'm getting
back to a picture I brought up earlier
where we talked about how fireflies glow
seems to be coming from this lantern
well what's happening inside that area
is that there's a chemical luciferin and
a protein luciferase and when they come
together in the presence of oxygen and
ATP does anyone know what ATP is energy
yep that's the cell's energy source when
all four of those things come together
the Firefly gives off light and it
creates this other you know it just
alters the protein what's interesting is
why fireflies glow can anyone guess why
fireflies Michael oh this is a tough
question I found it in doing my research
for this presentation
well one scientists believe that it may
be that you know since you need all four
of these components to get the lighting
you know to get the light for the
reaction to occur and to generate light
if one of these components is missing
the reaction stops for a little while
and it may be that in this area it runs
the Firefly runs out of oxygen
temporarily and so it has to build up
oxygen again and then it can go again so
and this is happening at a rhythmic you
know every six seconds that's the
typical Firefly that you see on the
Northeast is glowing and so I thought
that was very interesting that there's a
very chemical reason or at least a
chemical mechanism for this flashing to
occur another interesting point about
the Firefly the light that comes from
the Firefly is 90% efficient now could
somebody explain to us what I mean by
that when I say efficient
okay bye efficient I mean what percent
of the energy that's created comes out
as light versus heat now when you touch
a light bulb
how did that's been on for a while you
know you usually shouldn't do that
because it's very hot and that tells you
that light bulbs are not very efficient
at converting energy into light because
they they're giving off a lot of heat
does anyone want to guess what percent
of the energy that goes into a light
bulb comes out 40 it's even lower than
that yes great yeah it's in the range of
under five percent of the light of the
energy that goes into a light bulb comes
out as light most of it is lost as heat
so fireflies are incredibly efficient
and that's actually that's something
that's important in biology why do you
think it would be a problem if the
firefly generated a lot of heat when
this reaction occurred inside of it yeah
it would burn you and it would burn the
Firefly himself you know just like us
you know we have a very narrow range of
temperature that we can be at you know
we're normally at 98.6 and if we go a
couple degrees above that we're very
it's a sign that we're very sick so the
same thing with fireflies that you have
to keep it in the temperature range so
very interesting and here's my my really
corny joke I say that fireflies are the
ultimate source of green energy hahaha
really bad ok so now I'm gonna get into
a demo and I'm gonna ask for a volunteer
did someone come volunteer I saw the
first hand iced always back there
somewhere yeah can you come on up okay
can anyone tell me what this is
does any my reckon a glow stick okay so
here you couldn't come up to come help
me alright so if their glow sticks why
aren't they glowing okay so can you
break them break it okay what what did
you hear
okay does anyone know what happens
inside of a glow stick okay yeah I do
want to turn the lights up so we can see
the glow sticks perfect I don't need to
be here everybody knows all this already
so the glow sticks have like a Firefly
they have to a couple things inside that
when mixed together they give off energy
and that energy comes out in the form of
light you can you yeah hold it up anyway
and when you hear the glass breaking
that's just the process of you're
breaking it some vile that's inside
they're keeping those chemicals separate
and getting them to mix together thank
you you can keep those and ever we have
plenty of glow sticks for everybody to
play around with that afterwards during
the time for hands-on so okay now so the
question I have to for you now is are
fireflies just like glow sticks what do
you think
no they don't have glass that's true
anything else
how are fireflies yes the excellent
point
anything else okay back there uh-huh
awesome points oh that's an interesting
point two that the glow sticks come in a
range of colors but fireflies are only
green okay so that's interesting so you
get back to the point of why it might
run out because fireflies they use
oxygen and they you know you know the
glow turns off in the Firefly when the
oxygen runs out but then they can
replenish that but within a glow stick
it's closed so once the whole reaction
is over when it runs out of the
materials the reactions over anything
else do fireflies just glow at night and
during the day I don't know that I
believe so but I would have to get back
to you on that
okay that's that's really interesting
and I guess so she brings up the point
she asked if fireflies only glow at
night I think it's true I'm not certain
though but that because I know the
reason why I'm said I'm not certain is
that glow worms which are the pupa stage
of fireflies they glow underground and
so they have that ability to grow up
glow night or day but because it's dark
underground I don't know if it's because
of darkness which triggers it but she
this woman brings up the point that the
dinoflagellates which were those
bioluminescent things we saw in the body
of water that light up when you splash
the water they don't glow during the day
they only glow at night because they
need to build up some energy from the
Sun interesting very interesting
one more point excellent actually I feel
like I must have paid him you're gonna
think I paid him because I was just
about to make that point the big
difference between fireflies and glow
sticks is that fireflies are
bioluminescent and glow sticks are
chemiluminescence and bioluminescence is
it's called bioluminescence because it's
generated one of the components that go
into making the light is protein and
that comes from just a living organism
whereas chemiluminescence is all made
all by chemicals and that's something
you can make in a lab yes yes yes
exactly
yeah it's all chemicals good point very
good point and the other thing that's
common between the two is that they're
both both I think
efficient in terms of making light from
the energy of the reaction because it's
not hot when you put a glow stick on
your neck you know it's cool to the
touch okay so well that was all nice
seeing what Firefly luciferase is like
but I think you'd like to see the real
thing so I have a demonstration of
Firefly luciferase after I mix it we'll
turn the lights down but we're not going
to do it right now
actually no you can leave the lights on
because I'm gonna pass it around in a
box okay so this is gonna take a minute
or two I am gonna mix here scientists
have isolated luciferin and luciferase
the to the protein and the chemical that
go into the reaction to making a firefly
glow and what I have here in this tube
is luciferase this is the protein and in
this tube
I have luciferin and I'm gonna mix the
two together and we're gonna get glow so
on their own I mean you can turn off the
light if you want to show people that on
their own they're not glowing can you
turn off the light for a sec it's just
gonna be dark in you're gonna see
nothing because oh it goes the dims
thank you yeah on their own they're not
glowing right do you agree okay so turn
it back up okay so I'm gonna take about
a milliliter of this luciferin
take a microliter of luciferase
put that in there okay and we mix it up
yeah lights up I don't know if you're
gonna be able to see it I have a little
box to put it in see it might be hard to
see from so far away in the room I'm
gonna whoops I'll mix up another one or
two I'm gonna put it in this little box
and we could pass this box around I'll
get a couple of them going and you can
see so as you can see there was no
Firefly it was just the chemicals from
the Firefly yeah okay so when it's in
the Box you can see it I'll make one
more and then we'll pass them around
very cool thank you
what's that it adds oxygen to it it
makes oxy luciferase yes because that's
not a that's not a reversible reaction
okay and again it'll go around and then
also later on your hands on you can come
play with this a little bit too yep take
a look tell me if it's glowing yes
actually I have to make one more if you
don't mind me taking another minute just
to make one more
what was that
how many amino acids in lucifer's I
don't know offhand I'm sorry yes I am
thank you that's the introduction to
where we're gonna go right now when I go
back alright there we go alright okay so
somebody just asked this very question
so how did I get this luciferase well
one option would be I could go out and
collect a lot of fireflies and get the
chemical from inside them there's a
couple problems with this does anyone
want to point out yeah you'd have to
catch a lot of fireflies okay did anyone
else too want to talk about why this
might not be a good thing to do
mm-hmm okay yes it'd be hard to come by
how about okay someone back there yeah
you'd have to kill them it wouldn't be
very nice to the Firefly or fireflies
yeah and that's that's the other problem
is that actually might not I don't know
if you couldn't separate it because
someone asks before does this is this a
reversible reaction just the oxygen bind
and then come off again and I don't
think so so it's not really a good way
to do it and then the other thing is
that no I guess I think that's that's
the whole point I wanted to make about
that not very nice two fireflies not a
very oh I'm sorry
it's October right now you know you
would only be able to do this
demonstration one month out of the year
so we need another way and there is
another option we can have cells make it
because what do you think we need to
have cells make it I think have you guys
Lucifer and yep he's got it he said we
would need the four ingredients so how
would we get those four ingredients one
of them is a protein is that hard to get
how do you get the protein
yes excellent so he's talking about
genetic engineering okay so and this is
the big difference between
chemiluminescence and bioluminescence if
it was just two chemicals coming
together to make the glow you could
easily just make that in a factory this
since one of them is a protein it
involves some kind of cell or cell
system to create the luciferase and what
you need to do that is either the RNA or
the gene - for this luciferase and
that's been isolated so i'm just going
to go through this on how cells how you
can get cells to make luciferase well as
long as you have the luciferase gene and
a gene is just an instruction telling a
cell how to make something and if you
insert that gene into a cell and then
trigger gene expression then those cells
will start making lift separation and
you can collect it and put it in a
little tube like I just showed you I'm
saying the process of putting genes into
a cell it's called transfection alright
so we've talked about why fireflies glow
we've talked about how fireflies glow
now the final big question is how do
scientists use by 11 bioluminescence to
find new drugs okay pop quiz
why do we take medicine okay yes so we
take medicine when we're sick right to
treat us it made cure it may make us
feel better depending on what the
disease is what the drug is now the
question now another question is why do
we even get sick in the first place
bacteria okay what do bacteria do okay
and what does that virus do
yeah it gets into your body do you know
it specifically goes inside a cell right
okay and a virus goes into a cell and it
takes over the cell and it makes the
cell do something the cell doesn't
normally do would you want to add
something okay yeah some things can you
take the cell you can get into the DNA
and cause it to do different things so
the basic common thing going through
this is we get sick because certain
cells in our bodies stop working
properly and it might be because of some
infection or it might be because of
something something else going on inside
the body causes cells to stop working
properly so one of the reasons
scientists study cells is to understand
why cells stop working properly or why
they get sick and to test also to test
new medicines for treating these sick
cells so you'll look at a cell that's
not functioning and compare it to a cell
that is functioning and by seeing what's
different you understand the cause of
the illness and then likewise if you
then treat it with a count you know with
a drug and and then look you could see
if that drug is working or not so and I
know that's very basic but I wanted to
bring that up as a way to introduce why
scientists use luciferase to study cells
or how they do it well what they do is
they identify a part of the cell that
they want to study this is have you guys
taken biology cell biology do you know
parts of the cell can somebody name some
parts of the self I heard mitochondria
cell wall lysosome cytoplasm nucleus
ribosome yep er endoplasmic reticulum
and you'll plasmic reticulum that's hard
to say
excellent so you're familiar with cells
you've you've talked about cells align
now the things we're talking about what
things you mentioned were things that
you can stain if you've seen cells
essays and I'll show you that in a
minute sorry
biologists add coloring to cells to
light up these different parts of the
cell
well luciferase is exciting because we
have the gene and it can be put into the
DNA in a Cell
just about anywhere so it means you can
light up just about anything and it
doesn't have to just be the end of
plasmic reticulum you can light up any
kind of protein that's made because
approach the cells are doing all kinds
of things you know they're getting
infected by viruses they're you know
they have all these different receptors
on the surface that are binding with
different drugs and those are the kinds
of things that in normal when I was
growing up at least when I was looking
at biology textbooks you couldn't see a
picture of that you couldn't see a
picture of those receptors because
nobody had a stain that could go and
stain those things but now we have
luciferase genes that you can luciferase
gene that you could put into the DNA in
a Cell right next to the the genes for
those other things and you know what the
luciferase does is it tells the cell to
put a little tag of this little green
protein connect this little glowing
green protein to this other protein so
that when it makes when the cell starts
making that other protein it'll now
light up and I'm just going to show you
a little cartoon of what I'm trying to
say so imagine that you're looking at
some receptor in the cell for something
I don't know let's say it's a smell
receptor in the nose okay this is a
receptor that when you smell doughnuts
this receptor gets excited and it does
something that's why you smell donuts
well we don't have stains to look at
that and so this is without luciferase
I'm just showing you an outline of it
you really wouldn't be able to see that
but with something like luciferase if
you tagged the gene for that particular
receptor now once you did something to
trigger the gene expression it would
light up green so this is really
exciting and this is just an example to
show you what luciferase has been used
to do this is a plant and luciferase was
put Peluso first gene was put into
protoplast cells and this plant was they
put luciferin
the chemical that reacts with luciferase
in the water that they use to water this
plant and so then the water is drawn up
into into the plant and then when they
turn out the light they saw that it
Cologne and this plant normally doesn't
glow in the dark like this I saw
something on Wikipedia some crate if you
look up bioluminescence on Wikipedia
they have a wealth of information and
one of the things they have is ideas
that people have proposed for using for
uses for luciferase and one of them was
to have luciferase put into trees on the
side of highway so that they wouldn't
have to have lightbulbs and it would it
reduce energy costs for the state can
you imagine
okay so this is getting back to what I
was talking about earlier about the
difference between luciferase being used
to look at things in a Cell versus using
stains now I'm bringing this back to
cell division because I wanted to bring
it back to the idea that we're gonna be
looking at cells to come up with new
medicines to develop new medicines and
cell division I just put up there
because I thought everybody has studied
cell division to some extent so does
anyone know the different stages of cell
division yes excellent
excellent so these are different stages
of where you know when to set one cell
is going to divide into two this is how
the cell these are different stages by
which the cell divides up the cellular
components and then breaks off into two
cells and when I was in school we
learned about it in this way and we
looked at stains nowadays with
bioluminescent proteins here's a whole
new way to see cell division watch this
and this
okay I'm gonna show you that again now
the lights are off whoops sorry just one
more time
these are pig kidney cells going through
mitosis and it's somebody tagged the
tubulin and the cell's tubulin is a
structural component of cells and it
comes to life during cell division
because tubulin is needed to move the
different components of the cells into
two different places so it lights up a
lot during cell division because it's
very active during that time so I
thought that was very interesting I do
have to point out however that this is a
different protein than luciferase can
anyone guess what protein wasn't used in
this particular study GFP I heard GFP
what is he a P stand for green
fluorescent protein okay
so green fluorescent protein you're
probably thinking wait we were just
talking about luciferase what's this
about green fluorescent protein
luciferase and green green fluorescent
protein are both bioluminescent proteins
that come from living things of course
if they're bioluminescent green
fluorescent protein comes from a
jellyfish though in 2008 the Nobel Prize
in Chemistry was awarded to three people
for the discovery of this oh thank you
and because it's been incredibly useful
now I'm gonna explain to you how green
fluorescent protein works and why it's
different than luciferase but I thought
you might want to see a little picture
first
so jellyfish are bioluminescent this
particular jellyfish is not I don't know
if it's glowing green or not I don't
know if it glows white or if it's just
because of the quality of the video that
it really is green but it looks white
anyhow there are green glowing jellyfish
out there but they glow
they bioluminesce only when light is
shone on them they these this particular
video is with a black light
but with green fluorescent protein these
these proteins are fluorescing and that
means that they're taking in light of a
particular wavelength in the case of gfp
it's blue light and then they reflected
out green now I'm just wondering if
anybody does this sound familiar to
anybody what is that someone's raising
their hand did you want to add something
okay so I hands if anyone wants to okay
all right so these are glow-in-the-dark
stars and just like we did with the
light sticks I want to talk to you about
how glow-in-the-dark stars are similar
to GFP and how they're different well
they're similar how do how do you get a
glow-in-the-dark star to glow yes yes
okay so you have to let it sit in the
light for a while and then when you turn
out the lights they glow can you tell me
something about when they do glow once
the lights go out
does it glow for just just a flash or
what does it do okay so if you go to bed
and you have the glow-in-the-dark stars
on your ceiling what happens when you
wake up in the morning they're not
glowing anymore but they glow you know
for a little while oh throughout the
night and at some point they burn off
their energy well my question is is
green fluorescent protein like a
glow-in-the-dark star well it's similar
in the sense that you need to shine
light on it to cause it to glow
however glow-in-the-dark stars are
actually phosphorescent and the
difference is that they emit this light
over a period of time they don't just
throw it right back all at once it's a
slow release of the energy so just to
review we talked about why fireflies
glow in the dark how they glow in the
dark
and we talked about how scientists have
you
bioluminescence materials to find new
drugs along the way we learned some
pretty big words we learned how
bioluminescence is similar but not
exactly the same as chemiluminescence
and we learned how fluorescence is
likewise similar but not the same as
phosphorescence so now you know I don't
expect you to have gotten all that I'm
certainly not a person who gets
everything by just listening to someone
talk about it we have some hands-on
activities you can come and take a look
at these luciferase reactions that are
going on inside the box you can play
with light sticks we have
glow-in-the-dark dinosaurs in the box
there you can play with flashlights and
then close it and look we have some
glow-in-the-dark crayons and then I have
some more videos of other bioluminescent
creatures if you want to look at it that
so thank you